the medical industry has essentially
created a you know a destroyed subset of
human with lifelong health issues and
lifelong almost trauma surrounding their
body now and kicked them out the back
door because it doesn't look good on
their
stats here I get phone calls from D
transitioners that are
suicidal that they call me I can't go on
I won't leave my house I don't know what
I am I have removed all my body parts
there's a young man in San Francisco who
called two Fridays ago um he was in a
psychotic break moment when he uh let
them uh remove his genitals he's
29 he's a straight guy what do I say to
him what do I say to him to help keep
him
alive after the doctors have done this
to them